[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier diamant en affaires comment
va-t-il et parce que si ça devait bien
moins aller mieux
alors les enfants ou est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui on est sur la route de
takamaka qui est juste là et on va
visiter une fromagerie une fromagerie
avec du lait de chèvre
donc est-ce que je les prévôts suivants
- oui oui non
ben viens aux
mais je t'aime
[Musique]
bon je sais comment ça va écoute mais
aussi d'accueillir non là dans la nuit
devant un grand parc cabrisas un petit
peu déjà donc où sa nouvelle et ckoi
d'activité donc annulée à st benoît
hallé abondance sur la route de takamaka
d'accord mais tu sais quoi sans plus
attendre
moi ce que je te propose c'est qu'on ait
visité tout ça
[Musique]
et
alors là c'est si long on est dans les
tables comme on dit la chèvre heures et
la chèvrerie dix mois on en a combien de
têtes deux animaux dit alors il doit y
avoir environ 60 65 chèvre tu fais tu
fais combien de traître par jour en fait
donc de une le matin et une le soir dix
mois sur déjà une échelle et peut donner
combien de litres de lait environ 4 ou 5
litres in class voilà ce cas c'est quand
on est en pleine production on tourne
autour de 200 258 choque t on à un
souvenir on a un souvenir tic abri il
était petit o'shea comment on allait
jouer mais rappelle me faisais comme ça
bonnet sauter par a tout de suite oui tu
mens est banale et super jouissif abri
mais franchement un petit abri pour -
les plus jolies que toi du mois le
l'atelier de transformation de du lait
en fromage et les juste en bas oui je
vais ça côtés de justin maintenant toi
c'est vraiment ont tout se passe le même
territoire sur le même le bout de
terrain d'accord ok donc il ya pas de
gaspillage de nani des nanas non
non ici on travaille bien d'accord est
battu c'est quoi les thèmes du pouvoir
qui semble j'aimerais bien voir parce
que moi j'aime bien dommage j'aime bien
génial
[Musique]
alors c'est celle là on est devant
l'atelier de transformation oui c'est ça
ou ben écoute moi j'ai envie de rentrer
et on va voir comment il est à
l'intérieur mois et il paraît il paraît
il paraît qu'il ya un petit parce
qu'elle s'intéresse beaucoup à la mode
et par laquelle et des petites bottes de
fou pour nous la mènerons des petites
chaussures athlétique carbon quoi
demander vaille que vaille le modèle
avec ma taille et j'ai reçu illico les
pommes sur un plat allant mais le boudin
vous les trouvez comment
très cher les chaussures très cher
provenance de paris direct cuir de
crocodile direct crocodiles
préhistoriques se berce pas n'importe de
tête
[Musique]
et c'est la bande avant de partir sur la
suite de la fabrication en fait là me
voir qu'on a des salariés bien nettoyer
mais c'est du mutua ya japon va même les
murs le faux plafond et tout est lavé ma
toute façon pas d'hygiène pas de
résultats avant d'acheter parce que si
le dénoyage et matin le rendement chute
on a des coliformes le cahier pas bon et
ça se voit tout de suite et aujourd'hui
vendredi les jours du grand nettoyage
et voilà donc là on est dans la salle de
lavage et la salle de réception du les
salaires que le matin et l'après-midi le
lait arrive de la chèvrerie et arrivent
ici ils aient filtré
ensuite il est mis en bacs et
emprisonnés et il est laissé 24 heures
donc jusqu'au lendemain pour le moulage
donc le lait caillé d'hier donne là ok
ça c'est le résultat de mon d'une traite
oui et là dedans dans cette quantité la
tuer
combien de fromage mais ça dépend parce
qu'on a les fromages de l'île de
grammages différents donc on va parler
si on fait des fromages de sandra voilà
ça fait à peu près donc 260 280 fromage
de 200 qu'on m'écoute
on va voir leur est dû un de la chaîne
[Musique]
explique moi ce qu'elle est en train de
faire là donc on ne fait pas de moulages
direct en fait on fait du ce qu'on
appelle du preez gouttes âge donc en
fait on met le cahier en panier avec des
linges en fait et donc ensuite on le
laisse frais et goûter jusqu'en début
d'après midi et s'est moulé en fait
après dont commune qui moule dans les
moulins côté d'accor est là en fait ça
et ça no mire environ 15 heures
donc là il doit être 11h jusqu'à 2
heures ça permet au lactosérum en fait
de s'en aller on a déjà une pâte prête à
travailler
comme dit gramoune la frime ce poids qu
il fait froid on est dans la chambre
froide avec donc les fromages
autour de nous quelles qualités de
fromage hâtif et alors il ya donc les
et tant qu'à 20 4 200 g les crottins les
bûchettes 200 g
les bûchettes sans drame après là pour
l'instant toutes les natures en juste
d'eau
les peaux ont fait en un film there et
on en fait également avec du piment et
après on a du sens dréossi c'est à dire
que donc
takamaka 200 grammes on fait aussi du
chant drame avec une partie qu'on sambre
et les bûchettes également et on fait
aussi
alors il doit y en avoir par là on fait
aussi de la faisselle d'accord c'est du
fromage blanc en fait non battu égard et
nature et cécile essentiellement me vois
ma cantine miche de pain la mort même
s'il fait frais la wii a assisté avec un
petit couteau mittapalli méchamment
vaille vraiment dur compte de la chaleur
d'accord
[Musique]
on a commencé à enlever le lait caillé
le mettre dans les choix les environs
combien il ya environ trois heures trois
heures donc là on remarque qu'il ya une
différence de volume bas parce que je
suis inquiet de l'humidité qui à la
partie le lactosérum est parti voilà et
donc voilà explique moi maintenant bas
ce qui se passe quand fête est belle
donc en fait
enfin oui elle enroule en fait dans la
dernière couche pour les poser sur les
tables comme ça il ya aussi une partie
du lactosérum bancaire qui s'en va et
après ma passé face au moulage c'est à
dire que apprendre les moules avec le
répartiteur et elle va répartir le
cahier en fait dans les moules pour vous
faire le moulage avec un litre de lait
en fait on a un rendement nous de 250
grammes fromage donc en fait il ya une
perte
au niveau du lactosérum d'environ 80%
même a quand même 80 x 100 alors sicile
donc là ça y est les dans le moule oui
donc comme tu disais et je vais faire
mon intéressant parce que moi aussi je
connais maintenant en fait le truc c'est
que avant deux parties elles vont
retourner le moule donc mettre un
plateau de se retourner le moule oui ça
l'est oui et ensuite demain matin elles
ont l'air dans le monde va faire enlever
enlevé dans le moule faire glisser parce
que là c'est des bûchettes notamment
dans la main et donc les déposer en fait
sur les clé recouverte les mêmes linge
en fait lorsqu'on le fromage est encore
un peu mou donc si on le met directement
sur les clés en fait ils risquent de
passer au travers d'accords et combien
de temps
va passer entre donc cette
transformation donc demain matin on va
dire que le démoulage effet oui
l'emballage d'emballage il ya environ
deux jours
tout joueur dans un souci de
transformation du produit ou là pour le
coup c'est parce qu'en fait quand on le
fait en fromage frais on va lamballe et
au bout de trois jours par contre si on
veut les laisser pour faire le fromage
affiné comment qu'on a fait là pour les
bûchettes 150 g elles vont rester une
semaine dix jours en valois et après
attraperont la trousse jaune fin donc
qu'il ya sur les fromages de chèvre et
j'attrape ont le goût de chèvre
également perdre on vous fait un bond
plus donc que quand on consomme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
essayez donc toujours devant le
le centre de transformation j'appelle ça
la fromagerie la fromagerie
donc on aimerait savoir un petit peu
comment où l'arrivée à cette activité
c'est pas moi qui ai lancé en fait on
est
on était on est à 3 donc c
le beau frère en fait lui les natifs
donc de l'abondance il a repris
l'exploitation de son père j'étais
d'exploitation un calme mais il a
toujours aimé les chèvres mais quand il
était plus jeune et donc au départ ils
avaient des chèvres à viande
et quand ya eu des petits un moment
donné en fait les petits arrivait pas
boire tout le lait donc en fait il reste
celle du lait il faut quand même très
relais chef parce que sinon après ça
fait les mains vite et donc le lait a
été très et au début avec ma soeur ils
ont fait des fromages en fait pour leur
consommation personnelle
puis après comme il y en avait trop ils
se sont liés à les vendre sur le banc de
la route de takamaka puis à saint benoit
xi à saint gilles et puis après ça a
commencé comme ça et c'est parti la tvd
relationnel confirmé ne va dire
là commence quand en fait elle a
commencé en 84 89 84 quand même donc le
mont mashako makaay existe depuis
oui mais voilà mais c'est la couche de
fromage tout les dégâts là bas tout va
bien mais coûte moi je vais étudier tout
simplement revoir merci beaucoup
dis moi est-ce que je peux garder mais
louboutin ah oui il faut les conserver
pour la prochaine fois oui non mais pour
la prochaine fois moi je vais aller au
mariage avec ça en boîte aller à plus
tard nous retrouvons
jetez les chaussures mais s g
[Musique]
je veux pas mettre les pieds
et oui messieurs dames toute bonne chose
a une fin et l'émission se termine en ce
moment précis je vous dis tout
simplement au revoir merci de nous
suivre toutes les semaines les samedis
et c est quand il a fait tout en média
zone payante en page et retient pas on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge mais non
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
imaginons miss wattrelos beige la pluie
tombe mais mouillé tu vois dans mes
rêves dans le bmi réseau l'auberge et je
descends tout droit tout droit comme ça
là voilà c'est donc là c'est la mi mai
[Musique]